all right well i'm gonna speed run my
first one because you know i got the
points you have no story no story it's i
i walk in i turn the corner first thing
i see is a jojo figure so uh who is in
there because i was
oh
joseph jones okay young joseph young
joseph oh it's a lottery figure it's a
lottery it's an a prize lottery figure
of joseph jones that's a nice figure let
me see that let me see that oh that's
good i was going to say i also bought
jojo figures from here and i was hoping
you didn't get the same character as me
yeah i hope not i wasn't going to lose a
point who knows
let me unbox this pikachu figure
careful now that's a lot
these are a pain in the ass when you
open the box yeah now you're gonna be
here for like five minutes yeah but uh
at the same time since we've gone on
that topic uh
i'll look i'll i'll open the box yeah
since we got on the topic of persona
five i'll show you my episode oh my god
there you go hell yeah okay i couldn't i
couldn't not get this because i i for
one i mean persona five is my favorite
i'll be here all the time track this one
open you should crack this one open yeah
wait so how much was this one then
this well let me see uh
so here's the question would you have
considered buying this figure if this
was last year because this was like 82
bucks yeah so this uh so the joseph one
is
250. so 82 dollars yeah and this persona
one is 200
wow okay
200 this is a really big box for what
doesn't look like it should be this big
yeah right yeah well like this is the
this is the persona 5 the animation
persona one
technically an anime figure crack it
open let's have a look at this video
let's check it out what's the difference
between persona 5 the animation figures
uh it's not the main it's that the main
character his name
is oh
no
he's main character he's main character
yeah he's joking we live in a society
sorry to uh any audio listeners this
week um plastic asmr
did you get the most plastic thing on
earth jerry
how many turtles are going to die for
this figure
all right
you're gonna have to like help us and uh
all right nabi and ashley uh this is
this is gonna be this is gonna be the
big difference between last year and
this year is that now we have uh oh [ __ ]
i'll just start tearing it apart the
glasses so you guys want to keep it not
my glasses yeah we want to keep the
boxes
oh okay okay that's a clean joseph
that's clean as [ __ ] yeah right was this
the pose that you did outside oh my god
no no i did i did the standard joseph
post oh okay yeah it just said do a jojo
post off that do you hate your poses
okay
i thought he said do the same jojo pose
and i'm just like i don't i don't think
joey did this i think i did this pose
like every time we walked in yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay is it on camera is it on
camera
are you sure you want to talk about
specifics it's not going to come to bite
you in the ass no specifically
yeah i would just watch your back if i
were you being nice
okay so this one's got like a full like
well [ __ ]
joseph very top-heavy
he's kind of like rohan where like you
uh oh he's uh
let me have a look at this judge
everyone jerry sets up this persona and
oh
this is quite the nice figure i wonder
why it's okay the thing with jojo
figures is i've learned basically a jojo
figure expert at this [ __ ] point um
jojo figures are weirdly expensive
sometimes
i've bought some so there's a certain
line of jojo figures that i don't think
are that impressive yeah they're
visually they're not that
appealing i'd say
and they're some of the most expensive
jojo figures as you'll see because i
actually bought some of them myself yeah
um
it's weird and i don't really get it um
so i guess it's strange but this one
normally when they're like this they're
pretty good the ones that move for some
reason are like triple the price yeah so
if you got like the shittier version of
this and it moved it'd be two hundred
dollars he's just like hi i'm uh i don't
like i'm generic main character
yeah there we go there's almost
my brain isn't working
he's so top-heavy he's he's built like a
brick [ __ ] out he's just his
[ __ ] joe star dude
his stand is very very big compared to
the figure like the the uh
the circumference of uh the stand is uh
very big
there we go
who did you uh first romance in persona
five joey i don't think i've ever taught
you about this uh obviously the best
girl
hell yeah hell yeah oh my god bro you
think i'm a pleb who would say futaba
yeah [ __ ] out of you thank you
literally
okay and i did second but futaba is
literally the worst goal in any persona
game thank you oh my god i say this and
like people try to crucify me you know
people who say they like futaba and
persona 5 are the same people who go to
maid cafes all right
it's literally the same type of person
yeah that's right i called you out
i'm trying to figure out where the chair
goes like futaba's the type of girl who
would say pogba's out loud you know what
i mean like why why would i want that in
my life
i don't i don't understand these jokes
but funny you should play persona 5 and
you'll understand
you would you would know if you played
persona 5 yeah
do you want a cheers in front of one of
my challenges or a generic video uh
which one do you want to do first
none of them none of them why they're
all pretty all right they're all pretty
all right okay i'll do the jojo one
first then all right
okay oh jolly nice but look at the price
what it's two hundred dollars for jordan
why did you buy a 200 figure of jolene i
didn't want to spend much money in the
store and i wanted a figure and i needed
one that would put me over my budge over
the 500 minutes oh this is a sass as
well they're usually like rather
expensive so these are the ones yeah
sasa super action uh statues
these ones are always so expensive and i
don't think they look as good as the
others
oh and lie i think that jonathan one is
cooler than this jelly mom yeah i mean i
can i can take it out but
it's just it doesn't
you know what it's a bit of a pain in
the ass you know what it looks like yeah
i'm not gonna do it and this is opened
and it's 200 dollars i don't know what
this would be
what makes them that like much price
it's it's the hype of part six the hyper
part six yeah i'm not entirely sure i
reckon it is
because you you said there were that
there were a lot of expensive jojo
figures these are the expensive ones
like or that that figure line yes yeah
the sasses are very expensive the
movable figure lines for some reason are
quite expensive but jojo uh maybe a
figure expert uh can tell me why out
there i don't really know maybe maybe
it's more difficult to design figures
that move it could be yeah there's also
a lot of like movable parts as well i
think yeah but like i feel like with
removable figures i i feel like the
static one
static ones actually generally i've
always said this i prefer static i i do
too i i i don't want to think about
posing it i don't yeah i despise the
little pieces that you have with it that
you can't put anywhere where do i put
them i just i just with the essay this
is i just don't like the the joints
having this like
expose and you look like it looks like
an angel because like what whatever pose
you have you put with the movable
figures it's never going to be as cool
as
one like this with like a static pose
maybe this one's cool because jolene it
comes with like her extended hands
like that oh that's kind of cool that's
don't forget i haven't seen that before
so perhaps this is quite a unique one
because there's like
she has extended fingers here
but yeah i suppose two hundred dollars
though
god damn
that's that's a big span
it's the same as this yeah
sorry i know